a few more liberal Republicans are
pushing a bill in the house to legalize
daca and protect the so-called dreamers
from deportation House Speaker Paul Ryan
dismissed the measure as a show pony and
said he wants a bill that the president
can sign the bill is also at odds with
house conservatives who favor
Congressman Bob Goodlatte stuff smart
pragmatic immigration enforcement
measure let's discuss was his all
heading and there's like a three-card
Monte going on there on immigration day
brat from Virginia Dave like this is
wild because people were talking about
this this moderate liberal Republican
push for a doctor bill and saying oh
that's the pathway to the Goodlatte bill
what so the pathway to the Goodlatte
bill it's a nightmare yeah so there's
this complicated technical thing called
queen of the hill okay I don't want to
hear about four bills in play in my
rating Goodlatte won't pass so what does
pass the dreamer bill so the dreamers
3.6 million dreamers with chained and
ten years it's ten million illegals
granted migration pathway to citizenship
and that's what's in play and so speaker
Ryan at the beginning of the year said
we're gonna pass the Goodlatte bill it's
in committee members of the committee
told me today it hasn't passed out of
committee yet and so that's the first
step right if they want to whip it it's
called whipping for a reason they can
get the good lap okay what everyone
watching needs to know tonight is that
Paul Ryan we'd like Paul Ryan but he's
on his way out has not moved this bill
in the committee the committee has to
move it out to consider a vote in the
floor but that's have to go through the
Senate said it's not gonna approve the
Goodlatte bill what do you have 60 votes
in the Senate this is a problem and that
you could use it for the midterms and
the president tonight can I play
something for you yes tonight was an
Indiana this made me smile let's watch
Joe Donnelly voted against enhanced
vetting
think of that
what what in the world would anybody be
doing voting against enhanced vetting
why yeah that's exactly right
ants fighting for people coming into the
country yeah I don't know who they are
why they're here they're the refugees or
any of these other play and the
Goodlatte bill does everything we want
right Iver if I end chain migration
solves the border builds the wall
everything that's rational policy
senator Obama was for all of that you
know five by the way oh yeah it was all
this reporter hawk and and I just want
to point out the good lap bill is to
compromise right the Democrats asked us
700,000 doc could get him out of the
shadows give him a pathway to status we
said okay we'll compromise with you
Trump then offers two million a bigger
compromise and Democrats say no and so
now we are group we got twenty five
Republicans doing an end run with two
hundred Democrats right that's the play
if the people at home and missed the
main point it's twenty five Republicans
leapfrog and over leadership leadership
says show pony but if they get twenty
five so all they need is ninety five
that you know that we can go with the
Democrats and Daka is all the land that
think so that's the problem so if
everybody watching understand we need
the good luck bill this thing it's a
trick pony it's not a show pony it's a
Trojan horse it's every equine we can't
wring toward oh no he's gone sorry we oh
that's really bad